In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for September 14 on which we commemorate the 170 Holy
Fathers assembled in the 6th Ecumenical Council held at Constantinople in the year 680 against
the Monatholites.
This Holy Council was instructed to meet in the Imperial Palace at Constantinople in the
year 680 and 681 by the Emperor Constantine IV.
George, the patriarch of Constantinople, presided over the assembled Fathers.
Agatha, Pope of Rome, sent three legates, and the patriarchs of Alexandria and Jerusalem
were also represented.
Three Western bishops visiting the city at the time were among the 170 Fathers, who
in the presence of the Emperor and in the course of 18 sessions refuted the Monatholite
doctrine and anathematized, surges, purus, peter and Paul, patriarchs of Constantinople,
mercadios, patriarch of Antioch, honorios, Pope of Rome, Stephen, Polychronios and Theodore,
bishops of Faran, and all those with them who had declared that Christ has but one will
and but one natural energy, returning thus to the heresy of the Monatholites.
Thanks to the struggles and teachings of the great confessors of the Faith, gone before
them, Saint Sofronios of Jerusalem, and Saint Maximus the Confessor, the Holy Fathers
declared that the will or energy relates always to the nature and not to the person.
And that consequently, Christ is to be confessed as one single divine human person, Epostasis,
with two wills, or natural energies, the one divine and the other human, united without
confusion.
The unique person of the incarnate word has joined human nature and divine nature by a reciprocal
indwelling, Bericoreses, but has preserved the characteristics of each nature so that just
as the Godhead has taken our flesh, so also in the same measure our humanity has been
deified in its totality.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.